okay let's get started
um
last session before uh the social at
five it's so
um but before that I want to introduce
you to Diego who's speaking first
um he's a machine learning engineer at
Dell
as you can see and Sabin is a CTO of
outbound
um yeah they were going to talk about ml
infrastructure and yeah please take it
away
thank you thanks everyone for joining
this presentation it's seriously a
privilege and honor to be here and part
of the Spy data community and also share
some of the wisdom and knowledge that we
have experienced while building these
machine learning infrastructures in the
production systems as he said I'm from
Dell I I lead the Dell's infrastructure
services division for making all these
machine learning decisions that is going
to be necessary to deliver these models
in production that's going to help our
end users
and
the talk which we are hoping to cover
today is basically talk about some of
the challenges that we have typically
faced or we encountered while deploying
and delivering these models in
production and how critical it is to
have various personas in place while we
build these models in production
so as we navigate through this
presentation what we are hoping to cover
is talk about like how machine learning
has transformed the industry and and the
overall landscape in terms of the scope
that it has on on this community where
it's not going to be an academic
research project anymore where you
figure out hey if the given image is
going to be a cat or dog it's like you
have some real-time predictions that is
going to be necessary to update your
pricing strategy or identify like hey if
it's gonna if there's gonna be a supply
chain or inventory shortage and a bunch
of other use cases that we have in the
market right and and in order to get
these kinds of use cases delivered in
production it's not just an academic
project where there is a huge gap that
needs to be fit in place to actually
build and deliver these capabilities in
production and especially as as thanks
to chat zpd the the demand and and the
ask that we have also had from various
stakeholders has been insanely high on
getting these models in production and
in order to do that it's the critical
component which is which is not talked
about extensively is how is the
foundation that's necessary to make this
Vision a reality
so in order to bridge this Gap what we
also wanted to take a step back is
mention about various personas who are
typically involved in making these
decisions and the first and the most
important use case that we actually want
to talk about is the data exploration
and in order to present this in a much
uh easier way to to consume this what we
thought of is consider a typical cupcake
example where there is a bakery
where in that Bakery they are trying to
build and deliver these cupcakes or or
even croissants and whatnot and and when
we want to determine like hey what is
the right price we want to give for a
product let's consider that as a use
case that the business team is giving
for the bakery data scientist group
and the first and foremost
Foundation that these data practitioners
or the data scientists in particular
will be asking for is having a data
and ah for having a data and having a
tool where they'll be able to experiment
experiment with these uh data points and
typically Jupiter hubs or R Studios or
vs codes are what they are comfortable
with and after they manage to scrape all
the data that will be present in bunch
of different sources so for instance
during our previous experiences working
with companies like teradata or Netflix
or even Dell for that matter we have
observed that data is not typically
present in a one single data store where
you can just get them all into your
production system and start training and
doing all that stuff it's typically
spread all over the place
so after you navigate and consolidate
all your data and ensure that you have
the labels that is necessary to
determine the right pricing strategy for
the bakery
then comes the piece like hey do you
have the corresponding compute
infrastructure in place
to do these training activities
and after you probably let's say you
managed to figure out like I I probably
have a kubernetes cluster that's been up
in some Cloud instances and I'm going to
use CPUs or gpus to uh to build a
training to determine the optimal
pricing strategy or the inventory for
that matter
how do you do them frequently and
repeatably so that so that you know you
will be able to get much better results
and typically you would have observed
that machine learning is iterative in
nature so having a framework like
airflow or Argo where you'll be able to
schedule these kinds of data ingestion
and feature engineering and whatnot is
what companies like would typically be
using and for for large scale
Enterprises it's not just a small
community of data scientists which you
would have typically seen been building
these experiments and running some
models right because there will be a
certain preference which few groups will
have where they are comfortable and they
have been working with airflow
extensively or Argo extensively and and
even there there's going to be a
learning curve for orchestrating this
entire workflow and then do this uh
modeling capabilities right then comes
to piece on how do you collaborate
amongst each other after you build these
experiments which is where the
versioning comes into play
and especially for
for production machine learning
applications it's not just a code that
is evolving over time
it's also the data element as well as
the model element that you need to
refresh to with the corresponding data
and then you need to version it to see
how these model has performed
historically so keeping these versioning
practices is another critical element
which is what envelopes you would have
heard in uh being spoken about in this
community extensively
and after you version these results that
you get out of the model
then comes the deployment
and different Enterprises have different
needs on how they want to consume this
intelligence that you would have built
out of these machine learning models for
instance if you consider this pricing
example is it a report that a leadership
team is going to consume to understand
like hey are these values that we have
for certain chocolate cupcakes or
blueberry muffins is it within a range
or not or do you want to feed this into
a database where you want to have some
historical track record of how cupcakes
had performed historically and and also
you account for inflation and understand
like hey given this historical
information we have observed for this
blueberry muffin pricing I want to make
I want to probably
increase the value for the cupcakes or
not right so these kinds of additions
also needs to be made over time and and
it depends on the place or or the team
who's actually making these decisions
and even in in large scale Enterprises
we have seen that it's not just one team
who makes these calls there are bunch of
calls that that typically uses these
kind or makes these kinds of additions
which means that the deployment strategy
that has to be done for all the parties
also needs to be consistent to a certain
way right and finally and foremost comes
the modeling piece
where it's not just about like the
pricing strategy I was mentioning it's
also about the inventory and Supply
Chain management do you have the
appropriate sugars that is necessary to
build these muffins or do you have the
cookie dough and whatnot how how do you
also have your inventories being managed
is another popular machine learning
techniques that will be necessary for
running a bakery and a lot more right
and that's the problem statement that
you would have seen data scientists and
business practitioners typically be
focusing on but the most important
Persona that we are missing out here is
a platform engineer who actually builds
and maintains and manages these
infrastructures
right and and usually what we have also
observed are
how are these models being delivered and
you would have seen certain talks also
on this conference about like like how
after you build and deliver these models
in production systems did you build
these models using some of the pii data
or non-pii data and uh and and if there
are some confidential information which
was used to build and deliver these
models is there a way where a malicious
attacker can probably invert the
contents of the model and get the data
that was used for training this model
how do you prevent and have appropriate
guardrails for your platform so that
even these kinds of issues can be
blocked well in advance
and not only the privacy and compliance
aspect on that there is another a
container Security Management which
comes into play where you would have
seen that typically data scientists use
a bunch of machine learning packages to
to run and build these models right and
packages evolve over time and softwares
have all over time if you deploy these
in a cloud native fashion how are you
managing and maintaining the containers
which are deployed as a service on time
so that even if a log 4J kind of
vulnerability comes into play you'll be
able to detect these well in advance and
send and keep the experience consistent
for the stakeholders right so and and
last but not the least comes the
compliance aspect
so it's not only about the
explainability for the model but also
the data that was used for the model
right and where it's being sent to so if
the models intelligence is being served
probably in European region or America's
region
is the data and the model that is being
deployed is it following the
corresponding compliance rules and the
policies that is enforced in these
countries regulations
how can it and and how can a data
scientist be able to comprehend all of
this which is where platform Engineers
comes into picture and helps them but
still it's too much of an ask right
where they need to be aware of all the
practices that we just highlighted and
in order to truly manage and deliver and
build these models in production what we
we are also trying to take a step back
is and and it's not only about the
tooling aspect it's also about how many
tools that are out there in the market
to basically address and deliver these
capabilities which brings us to an
interesting conundrum called the build
which is buy permutation
so should a team actually adopt an
entire single managed mlaps platform to
to handle all of these techniques or
there are parts of these uh tool chains
where you need to probably use an open
source product and another one should be
managed or should you completely have
adopt an entire single envelopes
platform and do it on your own right so
these kinds of build which is by
permutations are what we were also
evaluating and that's where one of the
popular tools that also came into radar
is meta flow so with that seven I'll
hand it over to you to take it away from
here
thanks Tiago am I Audible
yeah okay all right
um hi uh my name is seven up until very
recently
um I was at Netflix uh building
infrastructure for many of their machine
Learning Systems so uh if you like
Netflix recommendations then much of my
work contributed to those systems if you
hate Netflix recommendations I left a
year and a half ago so don't blame me
um but back at Netflix we were focused
on many of the problems that Tiago just
highlighted and we looked around trying
to find solutions that already existed
that we could sort of like you know just
like start maintaining and managing by
ourselves and build tooling that would
be specific to Netflix but we were quite
underwhelmed by all the solutions that
we found and we ended up building much
of the infrastructure much of the
tooling by ourselves and we open sourced
it under this project called metaflow
which now Powers machine learning for
many of the experiences that you go
through any given day so if you get your
recommend conditions through many of the
more popular streaming services
besides Netflix it's likely that it's
already powered by metaflow if you go to
zillow.com realtor.com looking for
houses then those recommendations might
be coming through metafloor if you send
your DNA samples to 23andMe that
processing might be happening through
metaflow so it's likely that you know
you've already interacted with this open
source project and for the next sort of
like 20 minutes between now and the
happy hour I'll sort of like you know
try to focus on like what were the key
tenants what was the philosophy behind
this project
what are the capabilities that this
project enables and how can you get
started and start experimenting with
this tool and see you know if this could
be sort of like a worthwhile addition in
your organization
so let's let's sort of like you know uh
talk through sort of like what what
exactly is a machine learning enabled
system right I think everybody
understands what traditional software is
you build something there's an inherent
expectation that it runs reliably
without human supervision that's why we
say that software provides leverage
that's why software is eating the world
and then there is an inherent
expectation that yes of course you know
like it produces correct results it's
maintained and developed by software
Engineers these people in these yellow
hats
now when we look at ml-powered software
then we are basically introducing some
kind of entropy into the system and that
entropy is coming in from data it's
coming in from these machine learning
models that are basically these uh
functions that are learning through this
data and the expectations still sort of
like you know stands that your system
runs reliably well without any human
supervision it produces correct results
and with sort of like you know some
definition of correctness and now you
have some new Personalities in the
equation these data scientists who are
now sort of like you know also
responsible for managing and maintaining
these systems in addition to developing
these
and and now the interesting thing here
is that there isn't sort of like you
know you don't just like build a machine
learning system or you build a machine
learning model and just like leave it as
is you need to work on it continuously
you need to work on it uh every single
day every single week figure out how to
make it a lot more performant and uh of
course you know then you also want to
make sure that shipping and update are
shipping your first version of uh this
ml system this ml powered application
doesn't really take up all your
available energy because then it will be
really difficult uh to build a better
performing model uh so so the key
artifact here is that how do you enable
rapid prototyping how do you make sure
uh that data scientists are actually
able to practice the art of science
which is all about experimentation
so let's let's sort of like you know uh
just walk through sort of like some of
the things that Yago had highlighted all
the concerns that any organization has
which is all around sort of like you
know how do you think about managing
your data how do you think about compute
how you think about all the concerns
around orchestration uh everything that
sort of like you know these days gets
lumped into ml Ops or if you're at the
bleeding edge llm Ops around like
versioning and deployment and whatnot
and then how do you think about actually
training these machine learning models
fine-tuning your foundation models and
delivering sort of like value to the end
user and of course depending on who is
involved in the project
what should be the highest priority you
would get different answers if you ask
tool Builders like me and Thiago we
would say that yes you know like making
sure that everything happens you know
secure and Safe Way such that all the
compliance concerns are well taken care
of the data is stored in a legible
manner everything is cost efficient and
we have complete visibility into uh all
the inner workings of these systems are
really important if you take the point
of view of a data scientist they
definitely want to make sure that the
infrastructure doesn't see really sort
of like behave as a stumbling block it
needs to be an enabler rather than a
constraint and they should get the full
expressivity of let's say the python
ecosystem to get their work done and um
so so they are sort of like focuses at
the top level of the stack versus for
infrastructure Engineers like us the
focus is sort of like you know a little
bit more bottom heavy
so let's see sort of like you know how
meta flow uh sort of like you know helps
with this uh sort of like uh problem so
when it comes to building or training
any kind of machine learning
um uh models it's usually helpful to uh
look at them as a tag and of course
that's not a New Concept there was a
presentation right before ours where you
know like the presenter was talking
about flight which also has sort of like
Notions of a dag in there like many
other tools out there so so the First
Fundamental goal is that can we make it
super simple and straightforward for
people to Define that so within metaflow
there's a simple notion of like you know
you just like Drop in this decorator
called Step it's it's a python decorator
and then that denotes sort of like your
node in your graph and then every single
function also then delineates uh what is
the next uh node in the graph that
should be executed with the self.next uh
call that you see and uh the good thing
is that with metaflow all the data
passing between steps is automatically
taken care of for you so that you don't
have to think about how the data sort of
like you know is moved and we'll sort of
like you know come uh quickly to like
why that might be sort of like a bit of
an important detail for machine learning
workflows
now um every single machine learning
workflow actually has to fetch data from
somewhere so uh now one of the big
things uh that sort of like is a big uh
uh has a big impact on productivity is
how quickly are you able to get access
to the data that you need so for example
what we worked on was shipping this very
high throughput uh S3 connector which
sort of like you know allows you to
fetch data at like you know 25 gbps from
S3 to your ec2 instance so that you can
fetch data that you need in a lightning
quick manner so that then you can start
sort of like doing your exploration and
sort of like you know start training
your model a little bit faster which can
have a huge impact when you are trying
to just like rapidly iterate on your
machine learning model
um now the other thing that metaflow
takes care of behind the scenes for you
is automatic versioning so anytime you
execute any bit of code within metaflow
all of that gets version the code gets
snapshot for you everything gets sort of
like a unique identifier so that you can
go back in time and I can ask a question
that hey you know can I actually look at
all the work that Thiago was doing six
months ago can I actually look at the
code can I look at all the internal
variables all the internal State and can
I actually Replay that entire compute
and build on top of the work that he has
done which can be quite interesting
quite an interesting capability uh if
you have let's say an organization that
has more than one data scientist where
people want to collaborate with one
another and reproduce replay and build
on top of each other's work and uh of
course you know like now if let's say
you stored anything in one step that
sort of like automatically made visible
in all the subsequent steps all your
subsequent dependencies so you can have
scenarios where let's say a team is able
to let's say generate certain data
artifacts certain embeddings or certain
specific models that other teams can
very easily consume just by referencing
uh what that specific execution was in
looking at those outputs so you get sort
of like a model store as a side effect
of just writing your work within meta
flow
um so so this is all sort of like good
and fine uh for most data scientists but
then as your data sets grow then there's
also this inherent need of how do you
actually go out and uh train these uh
models which might be a bit larger for
your laptops uh so in the metaphor
Universe you can drop yet another
decorator in this case a resources
decorator that specifies memory at as
128 gigs and in this scenario what's
really happening is if you look at the
start step as well uh we are basically
instructing uh to metaflow that this
train step should actually execute uh
over a list of parameters uh or params
uh with sort of like is 100 long in this
particular case and what meta flow will
do is it will happily go out around 100
parallel containers
each running a unique copy of the train
step and now as a data scientist you
don't really have to bother about like
yeah like I have a kubernetes cluster
running behind the scenes what exactly
is kubernetes how do I package my code
do I have to worry about Docker do I
have to figure out if let's say I have
some data set some data frame in my
start step how do I make that available
within the train step all of those
concerns are taken care of for you and
you as a data scientist can just solely
focus on the work that you enjoy doing
the most which is trying to figure out
how to sort of like best translate a
business problem into your mathematical
model
and uh of course you know this is all
sort of like good and fine if
um all you want to do is experiment from
your laptop maybe occasionally sort of
like you know spillover into the cloud
um things things sort of like start
getting interesting once you have sort
of like come up with a model and now you
want to make sure that yes you know like
this model should uh get retrained let's
say every single night when new data
shows up or when my model performance
starts to degrade what do you do at that
particular point it's likely that a data
engineer in your organization uh or a
software engineering team in your
organization may have already landed on
and decided on a workflow orchestrator
which are good at sort of like keeping
things executed reliably well and now
luckily with better flow you have
already declared a dag many of these
workflow orchestrators including the
airflows and the Argo workflows of the
world they execute dags as well so
theoretically we can go out and we can
compile any work that you do within
metaflow into something that these
workflow orchestrators can understand
which is exactly what we ended up doing
so with a single click you can basically
go in and deploy these things onto your
favorite workflow orchestrator basically
getting The Best of Both Worlds at that
particular time and of course if
anything fails in that workflow
orchestrator given the fact that we are
already snapshotting and storing all the
state you can actually go back to your
laptop and you can Replay that compute
you can actually reproduce that error
that sort of like crashed your entire
pipeline fix it and then again deploy it
back to your workflow orchestrator again
with just sort of like you know one
single command
and uh I won't bore you with sort of
like you know many of the details here
but uh there are many other sort of like
features and functionalities around like
how do you run multiple uh uh pipelines
um or like different variants of the
same pipeline uh together so that you
can a B test different ideas how do you
define dependencies so that these
dependencies are tracked and
reproducible uh across any uh compute
Target
how do you do sort of like you know even
triggered workloads and whatnot so if
you are interested in any such
functionality I highly recommend going
to the metaflow website and browsing
through our documentation if you want to
play around with any such feature uh
please do look at the metaflow sandboxes
that are available for free uh which
come with a kubernetes cluster and a
workflow orchestrator already deployed
for you so that you can sort of like you
know actually start testing all of these
features and functionalities uh for you
today
as Thiago was mentioning of course you
know functionality is one piece of the
puzzle when it comes to any uh kind of
infrastructure we also need to sort of
like Focus quite heavily on what are the
security and privacy aspects of it uh so
of course you know like any other Cloud
native solution metaflow runs entirely
on top of your public Cloud so uh you're
able to sort of like you know through
like we don't pre-invent how it handles
uh Identity or authorization so you are
able to very easily break in your own IM
layer on top of it and then really sort
of like get through end-to-end identity
and an understanding of how certain
activities are taking place within your
infrastructure and really sort of like
you know uh make sure that you're able
to understand uh whether a certain
specific action that happened was
malicious or not and all of those logs
are sort of like you know made
automatically available through all the
standard tooling that the rest of your
engineering organization and security
organization may already be using
and of course you know many uh large
Enterprises also do end up having uh
significant concerns around our back
policies so can we make sure that you
know uh no matter what uh if a specific
team is doing some work on top of some
sensitive data sets then those models
intermediate data embeddings uh other
artifacts are not made available to
other teams and whatnot so you can very
easily sort of like Stitch together a
variety of different configurations uh
we have like you know plenty of people
in the community who sort of like end up
creating uh these isolated sandboxes for
each of their customer teams where you
get sort of like this full data science
stack that's isolated from the network
and that sort of like you know affords
this additional possibility uh that uh
you do not sort of like you know at any
point in time leak out any data either
to the outside world or to other teams
who may not really sort of like you know
you may not want them to be in the know
of what you're doing
uh yeah so so just to recap you know if
you look at sort of like our giant stack
of ml infrastructure of course many
organizations they may land on different
choices for each of these infrastructure
uh bullet points uh but then what's
really important is that how do you sort
of like put a glue layer around these
different choices so that your end user
the data scientist doesn't necessarily
has to sort of like go through
um uh the pain of managing this
complexity all by themselves so for
example for data today you know we
support sort of like a variety of
different back-ends uh so there's AWS S3
there's Azure blobster uh one thing
that's missing in this version of the
slide is Google Cloud Storage as well or
if let's say you are bringing your own
uh data storage uh layer which has apis
that are compatible with any of these
systems that would sort of like work out
well too
um similarly on the compute side of the
house today we support AWS batch we
support kubernetes they are Community
has contributed sort of like you know a
variety of other plugins as well that
Target different execution backends too
and all of those sort of like work with
different combinations of your data
storage
um your versioning and orchestration
story is something that's sort of like
already handled by meta flow so if
you're running locally you don't really
need to install anything you could just
do pip install metaflow write your
workflow execute it it'll read data from
your S3 bucket it'll execute workloads
on kubernetes and off people and
everything would be version by default
for you
and then on the deployment side of the
house
um you can take that same workflow you
can deploy it onto step functions if you
want sort of like a serverless offering
you can deploy to Argo workflows which
is a kubernetes workflow scheduler and
then another functionality that we
recently released uh was an airflow
integration where you if you let's say
have an existing airflow cluster you can
also export your meta flow workflow as a
layer flow dag and then you get sort of
like the Best of Both Worlds at that
particular point and of course all of
this works with any machine learning
library any python library that you may
want to sort of like bring in
so just to sort of like you know recap
very quickly
um here here's sort of like you know uh
the previous slide that I spoke about in
this particular example you can have
your data that's it's in AWS S3 all your
compute uh can happen on top of
kubernetes it's orchestrated through
Argo workflows and then the data
scientist is basically responsible for
authoring their work in metaslow and
then they get complete isolation whether
it's sort of like in your organization
at some point decides to move from
airflow to Argo workflow to some other
solution then at least like you know
that the data scientist doesn't have to
go back and redo all their work just
because the infrastructure sort of like
you know decided to move from one choice
to the other which oftentimes can be
huge for many organizations
so yeah that's that's it uh I guess uh
this is the last slide
um we'll happily take any questions that
you may have at this point uh otherwise
we'll see you at the happy hour
thank you any questions
[Applause]
I mean I can start off what was the
decision to make meta flow open source
yeah I mean uh so this was uh summer of
2019 and of course at that point uh all
of machine learn all of Netflix's
internal systems were already using
metaflu and we started going to
conferences just like this talking about
the work that we had done and there was
quite a bit of inbound interest to open
source uh what we had built out and it
also seemed like the right thing to do
for the community as well uh that you
know we don't just don't go to
conferences and talk about things that
people don't have access to it's usually
nice if we can sort of like you know
play with those Solutions as well I
definitely had the same opinion for many
talks that I sat through so now here we
are thank you
okay up there I'm gonna make the run for
it
great thanks for the talk I have a
question about ml pipelines I'm not
really a believer in the term ml
pipelines I see we have feature
pipelines that create features we have
training pipelines that create models
and inference pipelines that make
predictions what's your take on on
metaflow where where's the where are you
adding the most value or is it all of
those or yeah I mean I guess it's sort
of like you know it depends on the
definition at the end of the day I guess
if the definition uh is all around that
uh ml pipelines are a superset of
feature pipelines and training pipelines
and prediction pipelines then that's
that's basically sort of like you know
where meta flow plays as well now of
course there are fundamental differences
between a machine learning pipeline of
this very nature and a data engineering
Pipeline and the two primary reasons in
that particular case are
data engineering pipelines at the end of
the day are a little less iterative as
compared to let's say data science
pipeline or ml pipelines in this
particular case where you just need to
iterate through a whole bunch of
different and possibilities and also the
compute requirements and the
characteristics of that pipeline graph
looks very different
usually like in my experience a data
engineering pipeline has a lot many more
steps than what a machine learning
pipeline would have but then at the same
time a data engineering pipeline is a
lot more skinny than a machine learning
pipeline where you may want to train
multiple models in parallel uh or like
you know do some sort of like hyper
parameter sweep and whatnot so so that
sort of like then lends itself to
different solutions many times and that
in my experience doesn't necessarily
mean that you're always sort of like
relying on an entirely different tool
chain for that but it's more about sort
of like how you organize that tool chain
and for training pipelines like do you
see the need that they have to be
scheduled I mean I I a feature pipeline
has to be scheduled right and a batch
inference pipeline is going to be
scheduled but a training pipeline you
know you they don't necessarily have to
be scheduled do they you know you can
run them on demand when a model gets I
mean completely just think about the
orchestration requirements of the
different pipelines I mean it it
completely depends uh so for example
there are sort of like Enterprises who
would let's say train a model once a
quarter and that's okay and then there
are many scenarios where you may want to
train a model every 15 minutes every one
hour so I don't think that you know in
the world of infrastructure or in the
world of machine learning there's ever
anything known as an absolute truth uh
so different use cases always require
different trade-offs different solutions
and uh I mean
many people do not want any kind of
orchestration capabilities that's
totally fine uh but then you may want
sort of like you know other Solutions in
the mix they're crazy okay thanks yeah
any other question
okay if not we think uh Diego in sewing
for this talk I really enjoyed the
presentation and the graphics very nice
thank you thank you
foreign
[Applause]